play anything I do think that we will
there it is there's a handshake we have
lift up and we have a
carolan wow a carolan so it going to be
Knight F6 yes Knight F6 yeah I could
only imagine Magnus going for this young
goes for takes takes and Bishop E3
Knight A6 played wow elegant way of
developing the Knight also teasing yeah
please take because then suddenly there
was a queen A5 check and you recaptured
the
the bishop like
this and that means because of Queen A5
check black can also Play Bishop F5 here
this is a a thematic idea that you can
try to trade light Square Bishops
because a queen A5
check yeah wow it's very nice yeah
Bishop F5 so it's not only Queen A5
check against against Bishop takes A6
but also there is this idea trading the
light squ
Bishops the geometry is beautiful for
Magnus Carlson but the clock situation
not so great thus far Y pomi at 3
minutes 9 seconds Magnus is the one
spending his time and he's on the move
he plays Rook
d8 yeah Castle is Bishop G4 so Magnus
says no no I don't necessarily want to
trade pieces he's pinning the Knight on
E2 on the other hand for example after
H3 where is this bishop going okay Yan
does not even want to ask that question
Queen D2 Knight C7 C4 occupying the
center making sure that Black's Knight
is unable to reach the Beautiful out
post on D5 but we talked about this in a
game earlier when you push C4 you could
leave the D4 Pawn in some trouble so
look at Magnus he voluntarily takes this
Knight on E2 and Jan hasn't recaptured
back at least not yet he takes with the
bishop and F5 Here Comes The Black
Queen yes uh this is the whole idea
behind that southerly black has
dangerous threats eventually F5 F4 also
now already it's a threat because of the
hanging Bishop on E2 is white going to
play G3 but then also there are ideas
like just sacrificing the pawn
destroying White's Pawn structure I know
it pained you to say the move G3 and it
hurt me as well I mean G3 F4 for sure
from the black side you rip open the
white king because the bishop on E2 is
loose so for yand pomi he's now the one
spending quite a lot of time and I think
that there have been results in some of
the other games I'll just quickly
mention arjin gy against vladis artv a
draw without a fight ni sarin against
Neil dubov a draw without a fight Shak M
hang on sorry to interrupt sorry to
interrupt but wasn't Bishop takes C5 an
option wasn't it blers E5 oh my
gosh it looked like a Miss there from
Magnus Carlson Bishop takes C5 take on
D2 that Bish on E2 is loose crazy crazy
it's tiredness everything but okay the
game is on we don't have time to to
analyze that position too much there's
also not much to talk about it was a one
move tactic which could have maybe won
the game for Magnus and it also explains
some of the quick draws on the other
boards they're exhausted they're hungry
it's like 1 p.m. in usbekistan so the
delays the appeals all of this stuff
have been unfavorable for the players
but these two are still fighting so
there's a knight on D5 nicely
centralized the bishop on F6 aiming at
D4 but as you're pointing out a bishop
for white can plant itself on D6 if
black does not take it on four yeah and
what a big Miss by Magnus and now we see
that he might be in for some trouble if
white plays the move Bishop D6 then
white will able to eliminate that Knight
on D5 and black is forced to capture
with the pawn that's that's a terrible
strategical position white will have the
majority of the queen side and uh how do
you stop that if you take on F4 then
after Queen takes F4 white will play B4
eventually push D4 D5 and again he has
an extra p PA on the queen side this
looks really nice for Yanna pomi so it
was a blunder that turned into a good
position Queen E7 from Magnus giving up
the F5 Pawn he likely just wants to play
Rook d8 next Target this D4 Pawn that's
actually quite difficult to defend I
really love these kind of Magnus moments
Queen E7 most of us would play G6 to
defend the pawn F5 he instead plays
Queen E7 to connect his Rooks and bring
it to d8 yes but yam was not interested
in picking up that f five pawn it was
much more important to protect the C5
Pawn in order to be able to break
Black's construction D5 It's a Wonderful
situation to be in Yan is also up on the
clock with with like 40 seconds but
Magnus will be putting up incredible
resistance after all it's opposite CL
Bishop Bishop's position with very good
drawing chances that's true especially
if the material gets off the board but
for now with called Bishops you can get
an attack going and the black king it's
uh safe but the F7 Pawn's in under
threat and B5 C6 white can actually
create a pass Pawn very quickly I like
the alpha zero though on the king side
yes H5 H4 Magnus is looking for counter
play it's very important to signal to
your opponent that it's not going to be
the yeah it's not going to be a oneway
traffic yeah I'm creating chances by
playing H2 H4 eventually white will have
to watch out for a well timed F5 F4
breaking the kingside pawn
structure and I saw Yan's King go up to
G2 and The Rook on D1 is very important
because if the queen moves from C4 black
might play F4 and queen E5 perhaps
signals that F4 is an idea just to break
down the pawn structure on the king
side yes and I think Bishop F3 is a nice
stabilizing move making sure that I
control everything and this pin and
Status Quo
unclear situation on the D5 was was not
toan's liking now he goes B5 goes for
your idea he wants to push
C6 huge trouble I would say for Magnus
Carlson unless he can get all these
pieces off the board he is worse I see
Rook D4 is on our board now we see
Magnus play it on the camera great move
you need to trade off these
pieces yes you need to yeah the end game
will be unpleasant white is completely
risk- free but black has very good
chances the big question is Queen D4
Bishop D4 and afterwards Luke C1
C6 you don't want to put the Rook to C7
it would be way too
passive I'm guessing then some timely
Bishop B6 will be the answer and I think
that black can throw in flick in the
move F4 at some moment uh because
Black's double pawns aren't helping but
if black can get F4 and try to create a
weakness there will be a chance to go
after some of White's pawns we see the
pawn push forward to C6 a trade will
happen the bishop will slide back to B6
Peter it looks like Magnus does have
things under control now yes exactly
this was the setup I was looking for
that how can black be sure that he is
safe this looks like a very drowish
construction and so if Magnus Carlson
can avoid that c Pawn pushing any
further he will have everything
completely under control and he's
getting his Rook active he is he
potentially trying to play Rook C5 Rook
C2 at some moment
wow but that's quite quite a risky
strategy I saw that he will just play
Rook E7 oh and isn't F7 dropping but if
F7 is captured C6 fall so Magnus giving
up F7 he's alsoe on time Suddenly It's
yawn down to 15 seconds yeah but uh what
Magnus is doing is very risky if F7
Falls the G6 Pawn clearly Bishop takes
F7 is met by Rook C2 luk C2 be careful
ah draw offer probably a draw her with
Bishop F7
s yeah because Bishop takes F7 Rook
takes C6 and the position is completely
level we see that both players had some
inaccuracies and they made some mistakes
and for Magnus missing Bishop takes look
at this they're talking about it C5
Bishop takes
exactly
exactly this is what they are talking
about because the point was that black
was starting to play F4 and the bishop
on E was uh hanging so yam was spending
a lot of time it looked like he find the
solution to it but no crazy and that was
earlier on in the game but it was a one
move mistake and when Magnus didn't
capitalize Yap she was able to get the
better side of this